I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason magazine
reasontv Reason Foundation and what
we're going to do for tonight is we have
four great panelists who are going to be
introduced by reasons education policy
director Lisa snow if you're in the main
part of the office by the way there's
plenty of seats back here if you'd like
to join us and see the people in the
flesh but Lisa snow is going to
introduce everybody then we're going to
have a kind of quick conversation going
over three basic questions one what
excites you the most about the school
choice movement second what is the
biggest obstacle that seems to be in the
way of furthering school choice and then
finally what we're going to ask the
panelists what do they imagine or what
do they envision or hope to see
educational choice looking like in 2020
so before we get started I want to thank
all of the people and all of the
organizations that are participating in
national school choice week which is a
nationally coordinated attempt to raise
the visibility both the meaning and
possibilities of school choice to help
create better educational outcomes a
better society better life for kids for
parents for local communities all over
the country without further ado here's
Lisa Snell to introduce our panelists
thanks Nick all right well thank you
guys so much for joining us to celebrate
national school choice week and this is
actually the kickoff so you guys are at
the very maybe not the very first event
but one of the first events and it's my
pleasure tonight to introduce first of
all it's appropriate to start with
Virginia Virginia Walden Ford because
she can really be called the big sister
of school choice in Washington DC she's
largely responsible for the school
scholarship and voucher program here and
really Virginia is school choice week
she is school choice week secondly we
have Rebecca Huffman and Rebecca works
for and is the head of the National
Association of charter school
authorizers and we have over 4,000
charter schools in the United States now
sir
bring more than 2 million kids so
charter schools have had huge growth and
at this point it's really about quality
how do we ensure that we have quality
choices for kids and Rebecca does that
work and she's awesome next we have
Patrick Byrne and Patrick is the founder
of overstock.com and he has been a huge
supporter of school choice and the
United States for years and then on the
end least but absolutely not least last
but not least sorry about that we have
Joe Trippi and he is a democratic
political strategist and he is most well
known for the Howard Dean campaign thank
you guys all for engaging in this
conversation tonight I am the pinata
okay so without further ado Virginia why
don't you kick it off and tell us what
is you know as we go into national
school choice week next week what uh you
know what is exciting you the most about
the current state of school choice you
know I've been around a long time I
think this is about my 6217 here just
working in the school trust movement
starting with charter schools and I mean
I believe in all choices what's excited
me is the numbers have grown so much so
many more people are having a
conversation about what can we do to
make sure the children are educated in
the best way possible years ago we
didn't hear those kind of conversations
it seemed to be kind of the best-kept
secret in America let's don't talk about
you know how bad the kids are doing and
now over the years we've seen those
conversations grow but not only the
conversations we see action we see
wonderful schools opening up we see kids
actually graduating and going on to
college and and in signing a way to be
successful in getting the American dream
and I tell i'm kind of a storyteller and
i know i have other panelists to move to
birth you know one of the things that
makes me excited among all of this with
all the conversations with all the
schools with all the programs is a
email I get just as I was leaving the
house tonight and this email was from a
student who is a sophomore in
biochemistry at Syracuse University a
young woman who was a opportunity
scholarship recipient here in DC and who
writes me every once in a while our
emails me every once in a while and say
miss Virginia I'm doing great and who
can tell you from the bottom of her
heart that had it not been for a chance
to go to a school that best served her
then she would not be at Syracuse in
biochemistry and do him well Rebecca
make sure your mics on and have added
what uh what excites you the most
there's a lot of things that exciting me
right now in the school choice movement
how cool is it to see Michelle Rhee on
Oprah right and really talking about the
crisis and education in a real
meaningful way I couldn't think of a
better message to messenger approach on
marketing this issue because I think one
thing that we've failed horribly and in
the school choice movement is really
getting the right of people and messages
out there where it's been seen as this
right wing white man private trying to
privatize the education system you have
then you have Michelle Rhee an Asian
woman mother of two going on Oprah and
there was that so that's exciting to see
that there's you know that when I'm
getting my hair done that the ladies
talking about did you see Oprah and that
I didn't know things right well you know
these teachers so it's changing the
normal grocery salon you know debate
around education the second thing is
there are more that we're about next is
about to release this this fax report
around charter school authorizers and
next week and one thing that we a key
finding is that in the last three years
there has been a thirty-seven percent
increase in school districts that are
authorizing charter schools now what
does that mean that school districts are
coming around to the fact that they need
to have more public school choice
options in their portfolio so that's
exciting at a rate of seventy eight new
authorizers
year for the last three years so that's
exciting and the last thing is the fact
that we have hundreds of thousands of
charter school alumni of school choice
program alumni's privately funded
publicly funded voucher programs that
they're either graduates of college or
they're in college right now and they
are voices saying you know what school
choice works and you know we're going to
have a rally in Chicago next week at CPS
and there's a lot of there's a busload
of alumni of charter schools that are
going to be there saying you know what
you need to vote YES on these ten
charter schools that are before you
thank you very much Patrick a couple
things excite me one is that I believe
the data has gotten incontrovertible at
this point on the success of school
choice and voucher programs or whatever
your your brand is also it sounds a
little cynical because it's not a good
thing but what it takes me is the state
fiscal crises obviously that's a bad
thing but the entire state fiscal crises
as I've been explaining for about a year
and I think some of you saw me at Cato
the entire state fiscal crisis can be
eliminated if every state adopted
vouchers and about twenty to twenty-five
percent of children took it this entire
whole we're in goes away now we're
letting prisoners out of prison in
California although there may be other
good reasons to do that for many of them
we're letting prisoners out of prison in
California rather than like kids have a
choice it takes about twenty or
twenty-five percent of children to take
of outer and you would eliminate the
entire state fiscal crisis so it's
horrible as it sounds in a sense we're
getting to this this the finances or may
may drive us through the tipping point
we've been trying to get through now to
the trip you point you know I actually
think the thing that excites me the most
is the expansion of the conversation I
mean what school choice week for
instance about really and the reason I'm
here is to to expand the conversation
about what we can do to improve
education and make a difference for our
kids and get more competitive get get
more kids into into a path to a future
that helps the country and themselves
and
that conversation has to include
everybody and I think can't include any
can't be one option over any other it's
a bet it's a real discussion across the
ideological spectrum about what we need
to do together as Americans to to get
the country our children the best future
and that wanting it not popular than I'm
going to say is that I believe that
includes trying to get the Union
involved in the conversation which I
know like ah but I believe like
everybody has to be involved in that
conversation if they don't want to
participate that's there you know that's
it but they need to be invited to the
table and I think that's why i like
about school choice week it's really
about inviting everybody into the
conversation across the political
spectrum to join together as Americans
about what we need to do to give our
kids a better future and and that's why
that's of the thing that excites me the
most people don't want to come to the
table and have that discussion nothing I
can do or anybody else can do about that
but that there's a real opportunity now
to get that discussion going everywhere
in the country and letting citizens in
particular regardless of what's
happening at the top teachers citizens
parents coming together having that
discussion that's what really i think is
excites me about about what's going on
right now thank you Joe for the second
question will mix up the order a little
bit Patrick why don't you start off by
talking about what you see is the
biggest obstacle to progress in the
broadly defined school choice movement
well frankly I think it's the I wouldn't
even say the union judge has talked
about in fact I do think we agree on an
aspect of this I don't think we should
think of the Union as being the problem
we should think of the guild as being
the problem and the guild is doing with
gills have done since the Middle Ages
Wells's since the Roman at times they're
they're just trying to set up barriers
and extract monopolist rent and it isn't
just the Union it's remember that behind
the school behind your local high school
there's all these layers of bureaucracy
you never see there's the district the
county the state defense
now when you attack them they trot out
the teachers and say oh you don't like
this way but you know there's 350,000
dot 344 thousand dollars going into the
system for and the tea costs about
eighty thousand dollars to put a teacher
pay or benefits put her up rent a
classroom and so forth so there's two
hundred and sixty four thousand dollars
going missing somewhere between what
she's getting and how much is pouring
into the system so that's the guild and
it's really a mistake to just think of
that as the union it's this whole this
whole system so I think you know no
reason even be mad at them they're just
but the monopoly is doing what
monopolies are supposed to do that's the
whole point business guys try to get
monopolies to do exactly what it's doing
there's no point in cursing the monopoly
there's point breaking it up so i think
that the guild is the biggest I think
inclusively understood is the biggest
opposition to progress great thank you
Joe do you want to go next what do you
say is the big obstacle look what I
think is the great hospital that just
about everything including both
political parties and I mean it just
about everything that we've got is the
systems become clogged up and it's the
system I mean I one sense it kind of
agree about the guilt kind of concept is
it the system is just so like entrenched
it's really not the tea it's it's really
not even the in its all operating under
a system that's just like a bad like the
battery cables that don't quite work
because they got all that stuff all over
them and then and then it needs to get
we need to revitalize it and change it
even if it's just to clean all that
stuff up and find you know and put new
cables on I mean if something has to
change how we come to that conclusion in
the society I think it the only way to
do that is from the bottom with people
who parents teachers people in the
community coming together and try and
pushing more decision-making tool
community and in trying to get get
people to participate in a new and
different way because right now we've
all been sort of a lot of Americans have
operated under the well the rusty cables
still sort of start the engine yeah
cranks you know for a long time and
maybe everyone smile doesn't quite start
but it does in and so I can go on and
worry about everything else now we got
to start people have to start
participating start really thinking
about this you know the wake up call has
to happen now what changes in it that's
what we need to talk about what are
what's the right change and how does
that happen Virginia why don't you take
a shot at it you know I actually agreed
but what I see I with what you're saying
I do think that we have to clean up the
battery so we can you know get get a
good really going but what I see
happening in the community a lot of time
it's a lot of misinformation you know
when we're trying to get parents out or
trying to get parents to advocate on
behalf of their children you know
they've been told one thing and and we
have to try to clear it up but but then
they look at us then are we the enemy I
mean are we telling them the truth or
it's somebody else telling the truth so
I think what we have to do I think one
of the biggest obstacles in this country
is everybody's talking to nobody is
listening and we have to figure out a
way to get on the same page and and the
bottom line and I've been saying this
for years is everybody's got to stop
thinking about themselves and start
thinking about who we're fighting for
you know I am never unclear about why I
do this ever I do it for children I do
it for my children and your children and
everybody else's children because
ultimately if we don't figure out how to
have a have a the same page conversation
or or put aside our differences or stop
being self-centered about what we do and
what you do and and let egos get out of
the picture then we will never figure
how to educate kids and that's what it's
all about you know you know I've said
somebody said to me today well you use
you say you support everything I do I
support quality education I don't care
how it's given I want kids to be in
educational environments that really
truly work for them and until we can you
know have a conversation and people's
opinions don't get in the way you know I
mean I have a lot of respect for other
people's opinions but sometimes and
especially in this conversation it gets
in way sometime and if everybody would
just start concentrating on who we're
doing this for it's something and and
this is something I tell the parents
that I organized in DC I say okay take a
picture your child with you put it in
your pocket and when you get tired and
frustrated and angry and and want to
just give up pull that picture out and
look at it I carry a picture of my kids
and and so sometimes I just want to
scream to the whole school choice moment
the powerbrokers the you know to focus
that are leading the charge is I want to
scream to everybody put a picture your
child in your pocket or your grandchild
or your needs are your nephew and when
you start getting them your ego starts
giving away or you cannot listen to
what's going on pull that picture out
and that's when until we figure out how
to do that we are going to continue to
have these fights and continue to have
these arguments and those are going to
be things to stand in the way of us
friend put children in quality education
yeah my answer it was about message not
that's okay uh I wit I was good to think
about what you're saying I just think
that we need to continue to tie the
right message to messenger um you know
the dick Morris's and of the world going
on Fox talking about this being a
fiscally responsible you know approach
that sort of thing that's a very
appropriate for that target audience but
when you're talking to parents when
you're talking to the beneficiaries of
school choice it has to be about this
being the social justice issue of our
generation and it being about our case
and so um and and I honestly think that
this might not be in the category of
biggest challenge but most we're at the
missed the most the largest missed
opportunity is the fact that we have
hundreds of thousands of alumni of
school choice programs that are not
being educated or engaged about hey your
product of school choice come back and
advocate for this there are hundreds of
thousands of kids I'm waiting list to go
to the types of schools that you went to
that God should go to Stanford and
oberlin and pomona so I just think that
being able to engage the youth
especially looking at the civil rights
movement when we look at lessons learned
I mean there were youth organizations
and student group organizations at
universities that really pushed and was
the fuel in the fire for the civil
rights movement we don't have that
equivalent in the egg reform sector and
I think that would be the biggest missed
opportunity that we have thank you let's
talk Joe it's ten years down the road
what what would be the best outcome for
the school choice movement well I'm like
with Virginia I don't really care what
it is as long as we've succeeded in
finding a way to fix it to have our kids
being educated given the best future
possible I mean we it's insane with all
the just when all the technology we have
Kendall's iPads the whole thing you know
it look at a teacher who's got to come
in and hand out you know a book that's
obsolete I mean from that it was
obsolete the day it got printed and and
we haven't even within the school board
we haven't changed just that just that
simple thing of how do these kids who
are who are like like so instantaneous
to the information flow that's coming
across every minute are being handed
books that you know that that like I
said of dead trees and we're just stuck
in that when do we fix that just I mean
would be actually pretty simple thing
for a school board to do but how do we
get get you know get that
that's what I meant about the kurose the
corroded kind of rusted up engine the
it's not anybody's in a lot of ways
there's no one you really want to go
blame anybody it's just hey wake up we
can't even get kids books that aren't
obsolete how how do you maintain the
status quo how do you maintain that
status quo how do we all at least
recognize that something we need to
change like yesterday we have the
technology it's there the ability to do
it and yet we still are like kind of
like sleepwalking kids through here's
the dead tree I mean it's just not the
way not the world they live in anymore
just that one chain how do we get that
that and many other things but that's
just one that sort of strikes me it's
kind of obvious particularly like is
someone who pioneered the Dean campaign
I mean all the new stuff that we've been
able to introduce the politics the
journalism but on can't on schools it's
the same you know the same oh there may
be a computer lab give me a break I mean
I mean it's just not real and how do we
change that Thank You Patrick what's
your vision education 2020 well I think
what's going to happen is we're going to
get a breakthrough in a few states and
we may be there right now and then once
we get to break that breakthrough my
goal is to is to protect it and which
sounds like a more conservative to
conserve it which may be more
conservative in this audience sounds or
is used to but i think the time then
becomes our friend once we get a few
good universal or close to universal
programs time becomes our friend we just
have to defend them time takes you know
the data starts proving itself you get a
you get a South Korea or an Asian tiger
in Indiana or Oklahoma or something and
then then the problem was I think take
care of itself very quickly once there's
a good couple good demonstration effects
it'd be nice if those were
in a couple of states or a few states
which had very demographics and problems
I agree with Joe so I think that we're
going to get sort of a stair-step and
then it's well and we may be getting
that first step right now I give the
next few months in a few state
legislators then it'll take two or three
years to prove itself and then then the
monopoly fails I agree it by the way I
have a lot of respect for Joe I think
Joe brings a great tone of civility and
perspective of the conversation don't
agree with everything he says but his
points about innovation I like Pat too
well Milton used to say that this is the
only industry or that you could think of
where it basically hasn't changed in 150
years somebody could come from 150 years
ago and look at what people are doing
and recognized it immediately not many
other occupations really like that but
there's not been there's been few
occupations where there's been so little
innovation and again I think they're
deep-seated reasons for that there's no
incentive stint of eight could you
before Rebecca gives us a glimpse of the
future of Education what are the states
that are most likely to have this
breakthrough that you're hoping for well
Robert Enloe are you here should I I
don't want to show flash any hole cards
should I keep this to myself what are
the states where we might see some
breakthroughs quickly indiana i can set
South Carolina and Oklahoma right Thank
You Rebecca education 2020
Oh Arizona so I live in a really
interesting environment in the city of
Chicago we have a mayoral race and there
hasn't been a mayor's race in a while
with with master date I mean Mayor Daley
um he has been a great mayor by the way
with this mayoral control of the the
Chicago Public Schools that's one thing
that we have in Chicago that's really
unique as it is in New York I think
we're going to see more cities big major
school districts having mayoral control
we have a candidate in that has a good
chance to beat Rahm Emanuel which is
surprisingly enough who included in his
education platform that voters are
included of it that money will follow
the child in chronically failing schools
as well as expansion of charters and I
sort of think so i think that we're
going to see more of that more mayoral
control of school districts and of
course at the rate that we're going
right now with so many authorizers
coming into the fold more charter
schools and investments in charter
management organizations that are
performing really well with underserved
students is just going to continue to
increase so that's you know what I see
more mayoral control because really a
lot of the reason why the bureaucracy
acts the way it does is because a lot of
people are afraid of losing their their
elected positions and they're afraid of
losing their jobs well with mayoral
control you know a lot of that can be
mitigated thank you and Virginia my
panelists have given me such incredible
hope what I'd like to see happen in 2020
is that every parent is able to choose
what is best for their children where
their children can best be educated what
is going to what will be the best
interest of their school and that's
going to incorporate everything
everybody said and a lot of work and a
lot of us that are going to continue to
fight as long as we can walk so that's
what I'd like to see I want to see all
of those kids that have so much
potential and have the all those sparks
in their eyes that we're seeing through
school choice programs i want them to
continue to to have those bikes i want
their siblings to have them so in 2020
i'd like to wake up and every child is
in the place they should be
and getting the education that they
deserve all right thank you very much
let's have a hand for our panelists
before we turn it over now to questions
let's let's take some questions from the
audience and please wait for the
microphone to find you and then if you
could stand up and identify yourself and
whatever organization you may or may not
represent if you want to falsify your
identification that's fine just say it
on the record place so we'll start over
here please be gentle with me I Brian
Maxwell from the Cato Institute I'm just
wondering what everybody's thoughts are
on the idea that there's there's a
difference between charter schools and
voucher programs and the idea that you
were talking Patrick about the guild and
it seems like that the guild is getting
behind charter schools in a way that
they're still regulated and still
approved and you know the sort of thing
whereas actual vouchers you know dare I
say for-profit schools in the future may
be swept aside by include you know by
not distinctively separating those two
things and if there's a risk that
voucher programs may not happen if the
instant you know if the institutions get
around this idea of charter schools okay
and if not everybody I also want to
bring Lisa Snell into the mix here from
Reason Foundation but if we did somebody
like to take the lead on answering that
you know that that certainly because a
lot of people identify me is working you
know they have the DC Opportunity
Scholarship Program the voucher program
here in DC but I mean I support charter
schools as well but that is a concern of
mine you know for the last five years
six years we've had kids in voucher
program in charter schools and and it's
been really successful parents have been
able to choose the school to fit the
child and the program did fit the child
and
though and in so that is concerned man I
you know I believe that parents ought to
have some control over the money they
spend for the children's education so I
am a big supporter of vouchers and but
because charter schools have not gotten
the ok from the administration so now
charter schools appear to be separating
themselves from the voucher movement and
which i think is just wrong because I
think that all of these programs benefit
kids and I think we need to have them
also it is a real concern of man so my
voice will be loudly heard over the next
few years I will be working with states
that are are implementing voucher
programs is it any way I can possibly
work with them I will be encouraging
people to look at tax credit legislation
for scholarship programs and because I
think that's a place for all of it and I
am I started out with charter schools
you you must know that and and in
educating charter school parents so I
believe that there's a place for both I
mean it has been incredible to be able
to tell parents you have all these
choices in DC and I'd like to see that
happen everywhere but it isn't certainly
been a concern of mine recently that
everybody's jumping on the charter
school bandwagon and kind of leaving the
voucher group along well speaking from
the charters I'm currently working in
the charter school sector um used to
lead an organization a Hispanic based
organization creo that advocated for
vouchers as well I do think that the
voucher sector has helped move the
Charter sector because I've seen it on
the ground where legislators will be
like well we don't want those crazy
voucher people to get their way we want
you know charters are more politically
correct right the union's not going to
hurt me as much so that's a reality it
really is but I I think that um this
goes back on this probably because I'm a
marketing background major is it's
really important that we cloak this
message
of school choice around all the options
that's the beauty of national school
choice week is because I have never I am
like so shocked pleasantly surprised
excited I want to do backflips that the
fact that all these organizations that
have partnered and signed on to be in
for national school choice week is from
the broad spectrum and I think that's
just going to help where people say well
this voucher stuff school choice stuff
is just in just these little places here
and there it's everywhere and so that's
exciting to me that we can you know
change the messaging to be more
inclusive of all the options and and you
know I just think that the Charter
sector a time none other and to we're
not out of the woods yet as far as the
opposition with unions and all that um
it is amazing to me that after i would
let a panel discussion after the
screening of waiting for superman in
chicago and right out the gate when i
opened it up for Q&A it was a public
school versus charter school discussion
well they're stealing money from the
public schools and then you would have
thought you were back in the 1990's i
was just like are you kidding me so you
know and you have the efforts of the
union's trying to unionize charter
school teachers i mean so there's a i
wouldn't say that the charter schools is
the love you know the beloved child of
the union's i mean did we still are not
out of the woods yet as far as our
opposition so I'll be quick I do fear
the conversation to generating into the
people's liberation front of Judea and
the peoples are but I think of their as
being a continuum the first step is
backpack funding you go to any public
school you want and the money goes with
you like Oakland the next step is
charter and then I see tuition tax
credits and vouchers as being the neck
the next step I'm a voucher guy or I'm
I'm almost indifferent between tactician
tax credits and vouchers I like the
simplicity of ouch errs but I think that
we should all be reinforcing each other
and everywhere I go I say hey charters
is absolutely a step in the right
direction on Wall Street they'd say it's
directionally correct I'm not sure I
always see the reciprocal support from
the charters towards vouchers but that's
okay but it's kind of funny to me
there's been something missing if you
look at waiting for superman for example
i went to one screen
had and there was a big conversation
afterwards the whole movie is about
choice which child gets a choice which
one gets a choice to go to a charter
school which one wins this lottery and
gets a choice about a charter school but
nowhere does it punch through and sort
of make the conceptual leap to say well
the goal that the issue is the choice is
choice once people have the choice so I
don't understand people who sort of get
on that spectrum if they understand that
getting on that continuum pushes things
forward why don't they make the leap of
going all the way in a sample let's give
everyone a choice because the opposition
isn't a great job of positioning
vouchers as you know just they've done a
great job of marketing our movement
unfortunately and that's why I'm excited
that we're able to be in a position
because of all these films not just
waiting for superman both the cartel and
and all these incredible films that are
shining a light on the crisis is is we
need to be setting the messaging now I
mean because the messaging thus far has
been you know I mean as a Latina going
into the community saying that I support
vouchers is like are you kidding me like
are you with those right-wing white men
you know rich Republican guys and I'm
like okay I look nothing like them okay
no but I'm just kidding that's bad
enough but you know I'm with them I feel
ass off okay I'm with whoever is going
to support our kids having the best
access to the best education and so I
just think that this whole we've totally
missed the whole marketing piece and and
and it's ours right now with the climate
of the of the messaging around school
choice for us to turn it around Joe did
you want to add anything I mean I look I
think a lot of this is kind of again
talking past each other in a little bit
i'll give you example if I were the
union or giving them advice it be go
start a for-profit school get teachers
in there with Kendall textbooks improve
its not teachers it's not the teachers
in the Union it's the system that's
busted up and not working I mean prove
prove it the other way around to uh to
everybody I mean because then
there's they want that why wouldn't you
want vouchers then to let your teachers
get into a system that works works
better but go prove that you can do that
and and think I think personally I think
they could because I I think it is
they're part of the corrosion to I don't
I mean the corroded battery thing but
get out of that thinking for a sec start
your own for-profit school and improve
it I think would be you know a something
positive that we could all kick around
and go wow that's that's interesting
well you know they could be the ones
that proved the right system that would
work but you know again we got to get
open to letting other everybody come to
the table and be open to that Joe by the
way how can you tell us how much amazon
is paying you to keep talking about
Kindles which are coming although that
thing no no no but I mean could
overstock outbid them I'm just using
that as a no yeah we know reference and
it's actually everybody could agree you
know it that's I mean that's fascinating
to think about you know textbook costs
are things that school districts are
always complaining about here's here's a
very easy fix which just you know even
if you bought them in bulk at list price
you'd be saving money well in like if
you have an economics book that what
ended with the great depression or simey
what why not have stuff that's happening
now be appended onto that that kids can
they know what's happening now add that
in into the curriculum to let them
backtrack back and forth between
Friedman and and you know canes or
whoever you know whatever the theory is
that you teach at all of them how do
they how does current day fit into that
there could be a textbook that's
literally current and sort of more much
more exciting because it's alive with
them and said you know so I mean I don't
want excitement that's clearly has
nothing to do with education so that's
that's something we all remember let's
go to my room in back here because you
really excited could you come up and ask
her question she was really high so I
actually had a question I definitely
support students having the best option
no matter where that comes from but some
of the things that I've read our that in
certain communities perhaps with school
vouchers that has almost created a
segregation like a going back to
segregation of school so I guess I just
wanted to get your opinion on how great
I you're like I have an answer so I
guess just you know how does school
vouchers in school choice support
low-income students and that sort of
thing sure my name is Julie Daniels and
I'm actually with the women's campaign
for him but just here personally let's
bring Lisa snow into the
question-and-answer here Lisa do you
want to take a first swipe at that so
that's kind of the straw man I think
against the school choice movement I
mean to date we have never had a
universal voucher program that serves
higher income kids every voucher program
has pretty much been targeted to special
needs kids or to lower-income
disadvantaged kids so to date we really
don't have experience with a school
choice program that actually serves
upper and middle-class kids we only have
experience with school voucher programs
that serve disadvantaged kids and
whether you're talking about tax credits
or vouchers or charter schools they've
actually come in and serve a niche
market which the most underserved kids
of all have been disadvantaged kids the
bottom line is is that we right now have
focused school choice on lower-income
kids and you know we don't think about
kids that take vouchers to go to higher
education or whose parents have
subsidized child care we don't say you
know parents will have segregated
preschools or segregated colleges and
there's no reason to think that you know
charter school operators private schools
in public school
that serve school voucher programs they
have an incentive to serve kids right so
that they get parents to sign up for
their schools and they don't have an
incentive to segregate or to
discriminate against certain kinds of
kids and so far there's been no evidence
that that will happen and it hasn't
happened so I think that that's the
least of our problems at this point is
worrying about segregation what we
really want to worry about is high
quality schools for all children that's
what Stanford that DC schools up until
recently we're ninety-nine percent
african-american in the last few years
they've become about two-thirds
african-american on the third Latino so
were they they were already segregated
kids going into voucher programs went to
schools where there was incredible
diversity parents have said to us my
kids have never been in environments
where there with anything but black kids
or Latinos parents would say my kids
have been in schools where there were
all Latino kids and now my kids are in
charter schools are voucher programs
where their kids from you know all over
the cultural spectrum and and so that's
cool that's very cool so despite the
opposition whatever they say about weary
segregating I'm african-american from
Arkansas did is not happening you know
we are getting our kids out of
segregated environments Central High
School where I would school in a little
rock then went to school is all black
just like most urban high schools so we
have these programs and we make them
available to our children our kids give
a lot more diversity then emits variable
Eve if the premises of your question or
false kids today are assigned by zip
code when they're in the government
schools and in voucher programs there's
more
versity as well as how children behave
in the schools is measured by to the ate
lunch the tendency to eat in a
homogeneous group or not they're more
diverse when they take a voucher and go
to private school so I just respectfully
believe the premise of your questions
false all right let's and i want to add
as the product of catholic school i wish
that my school had been desegregated so
there were more religions than just
catholic it was monochromatic that way
let's have another question i'm a john
Meserve I'm a student at George
Washington University and my question is
to what extent you all think tenure is
the source or not the source of the
problem there's the famous rubber room
article in New Yorker that was really
eye-opening but on the other hand you
know left when people I tend to trust
say that look other Western European
countries have tenure it's fine etc
thanks thanks and let me just add
something very quickly on to that about
tenure in the K through 12 system does
anybody know what the rationale is for
it I mean it there seems to be a clear
rationale for academic independence at
the university level where you're doing
research but is there a standing
argument for why public school teachers
should have tenure as an institution I
mean what does it serve other than job
security which is
I mean tenure is part of the problem
it's more that the way the system works
is that in every aspect of managing
human capital it's done very poorly so
on the front end principals don't have
control over hiring teachers that best
fit with their schools on the back end
unless a teacher you know and even if a
teacher right molest the student is
violent in the classroom is abusing
substances in the classroom even in
those very severe cases like in Los
Angeles I think five I mean LA Unified
has 800 schools less than five teachers
have been fired in the last five years
and LA Unified so if you think of any
other comparable workforce that would
let people go for competence issues so
it's just the whole labor management
issue like principals can't decide that
they want to math teachers instead of an
assistant principal I mean literally
they have no control at all over their
human capital in the way that every
other organization business functioning
group in America does so it's a labor
issue first and foremost and tenure just
continues to perpetuate the whole idea
that a principal a group of parents
would have decision-making power over
who teaches their kids and right now in
most places in America they really have
no control over that it's all by
seniority by who the district tells them
they have to take based on the number of
years that they've worked there and then
they're protected from ever losing their
jobs no matter what they do there's
other countries that have you know
tenure but it's a much more rigorous
process in order to earn it you
literally have to earn it and it's based
on performance and many school districts
in this country you just if you don't
get in trouble in two years two years
book you get tenure so okay let's have
another question yeah sir
hi my name is Greg I'm a parent of a
four-year-old here in DC and one of the
issues that's come up as we've kind of
gone the waiting for superman route of
applying to every school that we think
would be safe and effective for him it's
just physical space I don't know if the
panel is really here to address a
nuts-and-bolts issue like that but some
of the schools that we're encountering
there they have you know 1,600
applicants for first sixty five slots
that might be a little bit of accessory
so i think it was 600 was it 600 465
slots at one of them maybe mrs. Huffman
might with her with your breath might be
able to address that directly as far as
how how different charters are
addressing that and then I just want to
say mr. Trippi think thanks for putting
up with us this has got to be really
hard for you ok Rebecca do you want to
talk a little bit about the imbalance
between demand and supply well it's a
sign of demand and the way that um the
aggressive proactive school districts
are dealing with that is by allowing
charter management organizations that
have done a kick-ass job at educating
kids to replicate so next week this
rally that we're going to have in
Chicago Public Schools the the majority
of these ten schools are for schools
that have that are part of these
replicating models that have a track
record that represent collectively 7,000
seats so if CPS votes yes you know on
these ten schools those waiting lists
will get you know the demand much of
that demand will be met so I think you
know charter organizations are in a much
better position to meet the demand
immediately in the lack of a voucher
program but you know that that's that's
a huge imbalance that a lot of school
districts are dealing with waiting list
could you talk a little bit about what
what is the basic political tactic to
get say the Chicago Public School System
or Chicago politicians to actually vote
YES on expanding the number of charters
or voucher programs I mean is it just
the show of numbers as a people being
agree is it you know what works what has
worked in Chicago and I know what's
worked in New York is having mayoral
control I really add reform-minded mayor
saying you know screw what's best for
adults we're going to do what's best for
kids and really being proactive and
going up like I've seen Minneapolis is
going through this right now Minneapolis
Public Schools where they're actively
recruiting charter management
organizations from across the country
saying common start schools in our
community and so you know I think that
the the whole political pieces so you
can't get around it you got to have a
mayor that is supportive of school
choice and that is going to appoint
these school board members and these
school burners are not going to be
afraid of losing their positions that's
what we've seen you know has worked it's
not always perfect but it's it's work
did you have a quick comment thank you
for your comment I look I really want to
be part of having the bigger discussion
and to any way that can facilitate that
I think school choice week was a great
idea because it helps to foster a you
know that discussion what's the best way
to do these things i'm not going to
agree you know I I feel pretty strongly
that this whole system is messed up and
we can point blame it on everybody but
that's not why what I'm into Joe you
talked always been treated but with
respect from folks here so it's easy to
be here actually did you you talked in
your remarks about you know inviting
teachers unions or other educational
establishment groups to the table who in
your opinion has been the most welcoming
or who is showing up at the table from
the older style power blocs you know i
don't i don't really know the answer to
that i'm not trying to you know I don't
try to skirt the question I just think
it look there's it's it does it's it's
it's hard to get your head wrapped
around that change when you're so much
part of the way things things are I
think you know I experienced that a lot
politically when we try to change the
way politics was done in a whole bunch
of people the Democratic establishment
thought you know we were
were Martians with tin foil hats on and
that we had to be stopped at all costs
it would be very welcome in this room
right well and you know and I think a
lot of that's happening now a lot of
times with the Republican establishment
with tea party and other people question
what the public establishments in sight
it's hard to get the established folks
in the system to sort of like come to
grips with hey we really do need to look
at how we change this but I think the
more that's invited the better the
chances that will actually all come
together and find a solution it doesn't
mean that everybody will come no one a
lot of people didn't come in the
two-party establishments and some of
them may learn the hard way when the
entire parties taken over and changed by
the grassroots but I think the same
thing in this issue the more the
grassroots more people at home in their
neighborhoods decide to participate to
get involved in discussion the more that
force is the top to deal with it what
you seeing that with these it's one of
the reasons the mayor's are the they're
the first people have to deal with it so
there you're starting to see them open
up to two different ideas maybe not your
solution or my salute somebody else's
but they're they're opening up that's
where I think you're seeing the most
progress rebec very quickly the thing
we've seen but the head of the teachers
union in Delaware because of race to the
top and saw that as an opportunity yeah
i think it's a it's a mix of you know
the cross section of opportunity and
just reality these movies waiting for
superman and cartel is putting the union
and peoples on blast like this is
ridiculous what's going on so it's
really force randi weingarten all these
head of the teaching to have to explain
themselves to the media saying really no
but seriously I'm Randy well I have you
seen the interviews post waiting for
superman up with Randy one which she's
the messaging that she's using has
completely changed to be a little bit
more rational it's so funny living in
the neighborhood that I do word the
soccer moms are like I didn't know was
not bad like this is part of the wake-up
call of America is just showing America
it's dirty laundry so
there's a biology term an obligate
carnivore a cat is an obligate
carnivores dog is carnivore but you can
actually turn a dog into a vegetarian if
you and they'll survive and they'll be
fine cat scan their obligate carnivores
just they die you cannot make it count
of vegetarian I'm afraid I think the
unions are obligate I don't think I like
where this is Gaara I'm as inclusive as
the next guy I want anyone to come to
the table but you're trying to make a
cat saw Robin Carla's like trying to
make a cat a vegetarian they can't
survive as a vegetarian the the whole
point of the Union and the guild is to
prevent you from having a choice so they
can extract rent so we can bring them to
the conversation I'd love anyone to show
over the conversation you want but their
whole point in being there is to prevent
people from getting a choice so they're
going to try to slow the conversation
down and tell us that we need to go
slower and we can't do anything radical
and all kinds of things their whole
point is to prevent the choice well
under that definition that's what the
establishment in the Democratic Party an
establishment the Republican Party are
about is like to just keep it the same
do not want any change because an you
guys in the grass roots or I mean that
what I'm saying is it but we slowly yet
hopefully are changing the political top
I mean we have not succeeded by any
stretch of the imagination but I'm
saying that I don't I don't buy that
analogy I think I think that that that
their dogs and not cats you can turn it
in I think I think they aren't point is
that are animals that you're to be
domesticated right we can agree on that
Virginia for you know I think that we
can all agree that we want everybody to
come to the table well we can't do is
force people to come to the area and
force people to think the way we think
so it's something that a few years ago
when we were debating school choice in
DC the Union wouldn't debate me because
I talked about families and kids and reg
Weaver said I made him look bad
and I did it I did it on purpose but it
was like change and what I said to him
was change your conversation you know
we're having a discussion about
education and you're not talking about
doing what's best for the kids then
maybe is something wrong with you and so
I mean I think that we have to stay
really clear on bringing everybody to
the table but if they don't come to the
table we still gotta fight for these
children period thank you and Lisa could
you also you know one of the questions
raised by this conversation is also like
what is the union or and is it
independent of the teachers because I
know you've done work on how charter
schools and school choice we always talk
about it in terms of the children but in
the LA Unified School District in other
places actually teachers are really
benefiting from school choice so maybe
you can talk a little bit about how the
unions and the teachers are not
identical either so right up until just
recently most teachers had to work for
districts they didn't have any kind of
work life experiences besides you know
the system and what that meant was that
in a lot of places like New York City or
LA Unified the contract spells out what
time you can be on the campus you know
how many hours you can devote to
students after school it was very
scripted for them what they were allowed
to do so one of the other benefits right
of all of these kinds of new school
choice initiatives whether it's vouchers
or tax credits or virtual schools is
that teachers now have lots of
interesting ways to organize their work
life and they know this and once you
have a lot of you know younger teachers
now you know in some ways I'm very
hopeful because we have a lot of
teachers that are like Teach for America
teachers that have grown up under more
autonomy more control more
decision-making over their work life and
as they more and more replace older
teachers that came up you know and again
i'm not trying to discriminate there's
plenty of older teachers that are on
board for autonomy and choice and
controlling their work
as well but this has been a huge benefit
of school vouchers tax credits charter
schools is that like you talk about
Rebecca with the alumni of kids that
have grown up through choice we have now
a huge alumni of teachers so just to
give one example I am on the board of
two virtual charter schools in
California that used the k-12 model the
California Virtual Academy in Los
Angeles and San Diego and we now have
hundreds of teachers that manage
families so their role is to be a
consultant for the family because it's
more like a homeschool model where the
kids are following a scripted curriculum
with a computer at home with their
parents and the teacher is checking in
with them right about how it's going
looking at their work but a much
different role and you know that job
just wasn't available five years ago
there wasn't any such thing and so you
know and what we see happening now
though is a lot of public schools are
starting to relax labor rules at least
on the front end so all of New York City
teachers are now sort of in a free
market although the unintended
consequence of that is that teachers in
new york city became free agents right
but then there became a huge pool of
teachers that no principles wanted right
and so they were on the hook because of
the contract with the district and then
that contributed to the rubber rooms
because they couldn't find a placement
under free agency because nobody wanted
to hire them and so but what instead so
became a problem because they freed up
the front end of hiring teachers and
principals could hire whoever they want
and then they had to kind of take some
back because they said we have to place
these teachers but then that made it all
much more transparent in the media to
everyone else that there are these
people that for whatever reason are
undesirable employees that we basically
been warehousing or foisting off on kids
for years and so you know all of this
has happened on the teaching side as
well just that we have all kinds of
great opportunities for teachers and
they've become huge fans of school
choice because they've experienced
firsthand what
means to have autonomy over their work
thank you very much and that's going to
conclude our panel but virtually
everybody here is going to be hanging
around so let's continue the
conversation there's more booze there's
more food and there's more people
outside as well so I want to thank Joe
Trippi Patrick Byrne Rebecca Hoffman
Virginia Walden Ford and Lisa stealth
for talking to us and thanks for coming